and uh sorry david but right now we're
joined by world champion magnus carlson
ending the day with the win and ending
preliminaries in fourth
place congratulations minus sure
oh you're not too happy no
why not well have you seen the pairings
yes i have seen that you will face
wesley saw in the quarterfinals
yeah that's it's not ideal
but that's the way it is
is it because you have faced him so many
times that you're kind of getting bored
with it or is it just because it's going
to be a tough quarter final for you now
yeah it's because it's very good yeah
all right so what's going to be
the strategy now leading up to
quarterfinals then tonight
are you gonna take a break or will you
start preparing then yeah i don't know
um in general i'm extremely unhappy with
the way that i played
today um i mean the first two days
weren't great but
at least there were some good moments
but today was
was awful so i just need to to improve a
lot
to have any chance uh tomorrow all right
uh well magnus i can hear you're unhappy
so i'll let you
start preparing for quartz final against
wesley so thanks for joining
sure